gotta say the go to work on that thing
any UK we'd say they have proper bans so
I just noticed for them well we're right
by the pacification I don't think I've
ever touched the Pacific Ocean before
this is wet
that's three oceans I've now put my feet
in bridge it's not in fact read the
means so the cables in in that in the
big in the big bit bridge forgot the
word it will meter these little tiny
cables call them strung together makes
the whole like society so they're
socialist tendencies showing through in
her quite radically running late this
morning because we had a bunch of delays
and also I just have like five people
asked me to take that picture
it hasn't really been our morning
so we just lended the bridge had like a
basement lunch there and move before we
get on the bus and go to the Academy and
then we go on the bus but it was the
same right bus going in the wrong
direction so we're now back in San
Francisco the Academy though they're
expecting us about an hour and a half
ago an hour okay an hour ago
we didn't talk about this last night
what was your impression of Starwood
it was a good film you enjoyed it as a
till yeah okay so I know what I did find
funny was the fact that so by the time
this comes out people will have most
likely seen it there's our there's the
wit pants for the Millennium Falcon and
everyone at nuts in the cinema boxes in
American cinema so these tickets come
from the Dean of Education they're not
for resale they're complimentary thanks
very much for Rick the thought in this
place right I'm calling it now that's an
Allosaurus and calling it t-rex
pedestrian there's very few of these
skeletons in the world or to see one in
Oxford you know this place
jelastic we're in a rainforest were
literally in a biosphere
spared no expense look at the size of
this toad but that's my hand next to it
- literally the size is bigger than my
bald fist
what I'd like photography
hello
by top as soon as you see one of these
things you know what's gonna happen
yeah expected picked up as being bit
boring this place is amazing like it's
localism California stuff and stuff
every like interactive exhibits sis's
this is an amazing time here
mom I found seahorses seahorses my
school symbols an analyze the closest
living relative there's an otter seems
the Bull Crazy Legs
Oh
Oh
sorry about that the battery died let's
go again shall we
[ __ ] we're about to experience an
earthquake are you ready to shake shake
shake shake it off the city witness and
comes to light the busiest port city in
America
his will not rapidly with peacefully
live areas
and poor infrastructure
every single thing about this place it's
amazing but the design is incredible the
fact we have the aquarium and then did
they like a chrome bits down there
father into the ground floor the pubs
are heating the tropics which are cool
tax and most mars-like it would be in
the topic those please is amazing this
is a Foucault pendulum I haven't seen
one of these into the textbook in my
undergrad
confiscate the most definitive West
Country review of the other leagues of
ever birds in it you've got birds on out
can we find a thousand icing on a
musical at this time ago which I replied
a little bit
Californian kids are smart the questions
of the kids are just asking about
penguin Q&A we'll really good questions
like scientific you have 15 years okay
we are done here but that was phenomenal
that was like one of the if not the best
science and that's really museums a
little Vinci this if you're if you're in
San Francisco you can have to come thank
you so much AG for the tickets because
Tom and I both loved it this has been
mind-blowing ly good and we didn't even
do everything in the eggs we missed the
planetarium show that's right
both John Green and stunning turn of
events I find myself at the airport
we're about to head back I just thought
I'd wrap up the trip really and it's
been a good one I've really enjoyed
coming here Safra it's a lovely City the
conference is an amazing experience I
would say that we haven't got as much
Alice as we did need to you
there wasn't a specialization for us and
this conference was so fast invisibility
there are 10,000 people our conference
and left my hometown about 24,000
that inevitably you get a bit lost
there's not give me a lot of time
devoted to your particular subject area
so that's what I mean that's the
negative about HGTV I would say like it
doesn't support you happy Holi
the interns what it gave me five
typically but it was a great experience
coming up front you know it was um there
was great sort of networking chance Mets
and new people even if we didn't
necessarily make like friends per se we
I now have a bunch of people like I want
to email talk to you and I also buy
medical people I've met before it was
nice it was the perfect confidence by
thing I you know thank you to people who
organized their I think it was a it was
very enjoyable I think particularly the
later on you get in your career it's
gonna be more more useful because you
can you have fingers in more pies
you know enough to go to multiple
sessions bills contribute like I went to
about two sessions where I felt
confident enough to ask a question only
actually got to ask a question in one of
those sessions but yes thank you to a
Giri especially thank you for the
tickets to the Academy of Sciences and
thank you very much 2x stop sending us
here for our expenses
much they have enjoyed it here I'm very
versatile it's going home with him
Christmas because that's what that's
what the weights I've got twelve hour
flight and I think I've had a bit of
break thank you very much for living and
I look forward to seeing you all in the
new year and well this would be out to
Christmas but merry Christmas from the
for Christmas